today i have a sponsored video where i'm
going to take a few minutes to tell you
about an excellent online learning
platform called lectera i want to thank
lectera for partnering with us on this
video i'll also tell you about my
experience taking a class on lectera so
you can get an idea of what the platform
is like and about lecterra's approach to
learning so first some background
lecterra offers courses that help you
develop your business and professional
skills it's a new platform they've
already uh gained users from all over
the world
lectera's community of users is growing
every day
and this year lecterra won an edtech
breakthrough award
for best ongoing education solution
provider
they have courses on managing a business
team
courses on sales digital marketing
financial literacy job searching
professional communication time
management
really stuff that's great for anyone
looking to advance their career or get a
better handle on your own business i've
used many online learning platforms from
my experience using lectera what really
sets them apart is they use what's
called their fast education principle
like tara believes and i think it's true
that if you devote 15 to 30 minutes a
day to learning something it can be
extremely effective in developing a
knowledge or skill you don't have to
learn everything in a formal classroom
you don't have to learn everything by
devoting hours and hours every day and
many people don't have time for that
lecterra is an excellent way to learn in
small bits
with a way that fits your schedule i've
taken a number of courses on lectera the
most recent one i took was about
managing a personal brand
when we talk about a personal brand this
could be you have a landscaping company
uh with an instagram account
or you're a dog groomer with a youtube
channel
or you produce content online like me
and in the course like tara takes you
through the different steps of how do
you set it up how do you maintain your
personal brand online and market your
business now obviously managing a
personal brand is something i have
experience with hosting a youtube
channel podcast with my name on it but
it's always fascinating to learn what
other people in the field have to say
and sometimes topics you're most
familiar with are the ones you take for
granted you don't continue to educate
yourself and that probably guilty of
that to some degree so the course
explored how to promote yourself online
how to interact with audiences
monetizing content developing a
marketing strategy the first part of the
course goes into how do you create the
brand from scratch important
like tara walks you through the
questions you have to ask
when you're first figuring out what's my
brand's identity
one lesson was about understanding the
social media platforms themselves every
platform has nuances and things you need
to know the interface the algorithms the
culture when we launched on tick tock we
needed to learn about tick tock doing
what we do on youtube on tick tock would
not have worked just as an example the
course also goes deep into monetization
for your brand and your content
there was an entire lesson about
understanding internet traffic
seo
very important to know if you want to be
seen online
and one of the last lessons in the
course focused on strategy on content
itself
how do you create a content plan that
reflects your goals and your identity
something else i really like about
lectera
at the end of every lesson there's a
quiz that does a really good job of
assessing have you actually absorbed the
information and if you don't pass the
quiz
maybe you go back and look again at some
of the things you might have might have
missed it was almost never necessary
because the lessons are presented so
well that i retained a ton
another awesome thing about lectera in
the course i took about brand management
in all of their courses at the end they
give you real world cases to deal with
as exercises which i did a lot in
business school and it was great to see
that be part of these courses you get a
real life scenario a business wants to
solve a problem
and it pertains to a lesson that you
just took so lectera lets you take what
you learned and put it into practice
it's one thing to take a course and
watch videos it's even more valuable to
see it applied to real situations so
please check out lecterra i've put a
link underneath this video i've enjoyed
the courses i've gotten a lot out of
them a lot of business related topics
that you can study
marketing sales like i said uh social
media etc endless topics to discover and
again i want to thank lecterra for
sponsoring this video you can get free
access to the course that i took on
lectera by clicking the link right
underneath the video and using the code
pacman
you